the covid vaccine is now a go for kids
ages 5 to 11.
pfizer has already shipped dozens of the
children's vaccine and they are ready to
go in the state of nevada 8 news now
reporter sally jaramillo is live outside
of a cvs and she spoke to doctors and
parents and also shares their reactions
tonight sally
denise and brian there are 34 cvs
locations in nevada ready to start
giving out vaccines to children ages 5
and 11 as early as this coming sunday
now that it's available the decision is
up to parents
since the beginning of october children
in that age group have accounted for
about 10 percent
of the cases
of covet that you know have gotten
infection required hospitalization and
kids do get sick associate professor of
pediatrics at the kirkor korean school
of medicine david dijon says he agrees
with vaccinating children i think we
need to protect our younger children
children in this age group the dose that
will be given to the younger children is
one-third of the dose
that was given to the adults dijon says
child vaccines were studied in more than
4 thousand kids with minimal side
effects in most the decision isn't easy
for parents i believe in the science and
i believe in the vaccines
but i still am a little bit on the fence
of having my six-year-old daughter have
it
so i think i'm going to wait a little
bit after the holidays
to see
if
she will get it
maybe next year we also talked to a
father of three who says the vaccine is
needed and welcomed us as parents we our
job is to
remove as much risk as possible for our
children yeah it's just a matter of
scheduling it yeah i think
we're ready to go
out here live children are supposed to
get two doses three weeks apart the
shots will be given with a smaller
needle of course and parents must be
present sally jaramillo live local now